kind of um yeah he's
avenged the previous victory by playing
quickly that's the key he was too slow
in the last game and he sped up nakamura
now i feel that uh
somehow maxim wasn't quite used to this
position so he didn't quite realize the
danger of that white has in pushing the
pawns so far up the board on the left
i just i i'm surprised by the opening
choice by bachelor graph in these
situations where it's all about speed
you need to go back to your favorite
openings that's your only hope he went
to an opening he's not familiar with and
he was punished very quickly
okay white's queen now on a great square
black's knight forced back again to stop
the white rooks entering the seventh
rank
and okay i expect white's remaining rook
there next to the white king to mobilize
first we see a trade of rooks getting
rid of black's last defender there
that's good news actually because uh
though we see a result actually ivanka
black just resigns we're headed to
armageddon yay
nakamura laughing
it's a win for a car and nakamura